the first time you build something as an
entrepreneur that somebody pays you for
is a magical moment it really it really
you know what when you love the game not
the thing that has become which is like
it's so cool like quote unquote everyone
is like I don't think a lot of people
can actually talk about the first thing
they sold the modern entrepreneur right
they can remember when they raised the
capital they can remember this that and
the other thing but like the actual
first client especially if they're five
seven years in in this new era but I can
remember the first wine I sold from my
dad the first client bner media had like
all of it vividly I can sit here and
tell you wood 1990 chardonnay from
Sonoma Valley is like ingrained in my
heart